nouveau numéro de reporter plus le
magazine de reportage long format de
France 24 direction l’arabie Saoudite
qui fait parler d'elle dans un secteur
où on l'attendait pas celui du cinéma
tournage de film festival sur tapis
rouge pléiade de stars invités nouveau
studio ultra moderne le très rigoriste
Royaume d'Arabie Saoudite ne lésine pas
sur les moyens pour devenir une terre
d'élection du cinéma montrer les beautés
de l'Arabie sur grand écran c'est aussi
attiré de futurs touristes et s'offrir
une image moderne pour faire oublier les
atteintes à la liberté en général et à
la liberté d'expression en particulier
en tout cas la jeunesse saoudienne 70%
de la population à moins de 30 ans
s'empare de ce nouvel espace de liberté
et ce rue dans les salles de cinéma qui
ouvre dans tout le pays et chose
impensable il y a encore 5 ans on y
croise des spectatrices l'Arabie
Saoudite sa toiles c'est un document
signé Thomas paga et Mathieu Baudouin
pour France 24
[Musique]
trois jeunes femmes au cinéma
la Seine serait anodine par tout
ailleurs dans le monde
mais nous sommes en Arabie Saoudite
les salles obscures sont ouvertes depuis
quelques années seulement
auparavant ces jeunes femmes ne
sortaient que dans les galeries
commerciales se divertir le soir était
impensable pour des célibataires
aujourd'hui sa fille arrive et sa loi
fait une grande première
avant tout le monde avait peur
ou je ne peux pas y aller mais
maintenant tout va bien on peut parler
librement oui les femmes sont plus à
l'aise elles sont plus libres même pour
des petites choses du quotidien c'est
très bien le cinéma c'est un premier pas
voilà on fait des petits pas la société
s'ouvre progressivement
comme d'autres dans la salle elles
utilisent en permanence leur téléphone
l'Arabie Saoudite est déjà
ultra connectée mais découvre seulement
aujourd'hui le grand écran
oui je suis sur les réseaux comme tout
le monde là c'est ma première fois aussi
au cinéma j'ai vraiment hâte que ça
commence
c'est la fin d'un interdit unique au
monde en vigueur depuis 35 ans dans
cette monarchie ultra-rigoriste la
décision d'un homme Mohamed Ben Salman
prince héritier d'Arabie Saoudite un
geste d'ouverture au monde de la part
d'un despote décidé à appliquer à son
pays la thérapie du choc
70% des Saoudiens ont moins de 30 ans
alors honnêtement on ne va pas laisser
les idées extrémistes nous pourrir la
vie pour les 30 prochaines années nous
allons les détruire ici et aujourd'hui
mais c'est aussi un moyen de sortir
l'Arabie Saoudite de sa dépendance au
pétrole le cinéma à lui seul devrait
rapporter plus de 20 milliards d'euros
d'ici 2030 et encourager le tourisme
dans un pays jusque la complètement
fermée
quand vous voyez un film dans lequel il
y a un super paysage une ville vous
voulez les visiter
objectif redorer l'image du pays faire
oublier qu'ici les militants des droits
de l'homme et les journalistes sont
traqués emprisonnés ou assassiné un pays
où nous serons escortés par des employés
du ministère des médias pendant tout
notre tournage où la liberté
d'expression le droit de manifester ou
de critiquer la monarchie n'existe pas
est-ce que je peux parler de ça
cette opération de propagande repose sur
les épaules d'un monarque tout-puissant
qui a force d'intimidation a fini par
concentrer tous les pouvoirs il est
arrivé il a dit maintenant le chef c'est
moi et aujourd'hui décide tout seul
[Musique]
avec nos accompagnateurs
nous avons rendez-vous à Jeddah
c'est la ville la plus cosmopolite du
royaume
au bord de la mer Rouge
porte d'entrée des pèlerins du monde
entier
pour se rendre au lieu saint de Médine
et la Mecque
[Musique]
dans ce café décoré à l'occidental
une équipe installe des corps et
éclairage
[Musique]
nous sommes sur un plateau de tournage
une production saoudienne
écrite par Fatima el bannaoui actrice à
succès et pour la première fois de sa
carrière
réalisatrice d'un long-métrage
[Musique]
on fait tous les plans pour cette
séquence ensuite il nous faut le plan 61
celui qui parle du passé on va faire un
plan insert du père qui regarde son
couteau je pense que c'est le mieux et
ensuite on tourne le plan 62
on voit où elle s'assoit exactement et
on commence d'accord allez on y va
ensemble on va voir ce que ça donne
si j'avais dû faire ce film il y a 5 ans
ça aurait été difficile très difficile
mais maintenant ce que je veux c'est me
sentir prête
à profiter de cette nouvelle liberté
elle fait partie de la jeunesse dorée
diplômée de psychologie à Harvard c'est
une Saoudienne pressée pour qui
dirigèrent une équipe est une évidence
on se concentre sur tous les plans on va
faire plusieurs prises le plus important
c'est que celui qui est assis à ta place
fasse quelque chose qu'ils boivent du
thé ou quelque chose du genre OK
[Musique]
sur le plateau les langues et les
nationalités se mélangent
les acteurs sont saoudiens
le directeur de la photographie bulgare
les techniciens eux
sont libanais ou égyptiens pour la
plupart
il fait trop de bruit pour ça
c'est notre acteur principal qui joue
mon père
c'est une super tictocuse très naturelle
son film s'inspire de sa vie
une Saoudienne expatriée qui revient
dans un pays en plein changement
retrouvant son père en proie à la
maladie mentale
au milieu de la crise du covid
[Applaudissements]
critique du système saoudien de remise
en cause de la monarchie ni de messages
féministes trop explicite
vous savez tout ce que je fais c'est de
la politique la façon dont je parle aux
gens la façon dont je communique dont je
chuchote à l'oreille de quelqu'un plutôt
que lui parler devant tout le monde tout
ça c'est politique donc au lieu de
moraliser de parler je préfère être un
exemple que les autres puissent
apprendre de moi
la présence de Fatima al banaoui sur le
tournage est un changement considérable
dans un pays où il y a encore 5 ans les
femmes n'étaient que tolérées dans
l'espace public ou aujourd'hui encore
leur vie est soumise à la tutelle d'un
homme
tout a changé c'est un virage à 180
degrés moi j'ai des filles et je suis
très heureux pour elle les opportunités
arrivent de partout soudainement les
portes s'ouvrent et vous voyez émerger
plein de talents qu'on ne voyait pas
avant
les hommes et les femmes c'est pareil
les deux sexes peuvent s'exprimer créer
ont des histoires à raconter et je suis
ravi de faire partie de l'aventure
[Musique]
pour le cinéma saoudien
c'est une renaissance après une longue
interruption forcée
dans les années 50 des projections
étaient organisées dans les grandes
villes du royaume
[Musique]
des films
produits par les compagnies pétrolières
américaines
[Musique]
nous avons demandé à l'un des pionniers
du 7e art saoudien de nous replonger
dans cette histoire
sa carrière
salée fusane a commencé en louant des
pentes vidéos il se souvient des films
de son enfance projetés en public comme
ici dans le vieux de Jeddah
[Musique]
le cinéma c'était à la maison les femmes
ça c'est à l'arrière et les enfants
devant
les projections se passaient chez le
voisin tout le monde sera semblé pour
regarder le film
on faisait souvent ça pour une grande
occasion comme l'Aïd ou les weekends le
jeudi ou le vendredi soir
on se cotisait entre nous ou aussi
quelqu'un avait assez d'argent pour
louer le projecteur et le film on le
regardait chez lui
[Musique]
que chaque musique mais tout s'arrête en
1979 plusieurs centaines de pèlerins se
trouvaient dans l'enceinte de la grande
mosquée lorsqu’un commande au armé les
IA retenu otages excédé parce qu'il
dénonce comme le relâchement des morts
dans le royaume
de sang fondamentalistes
prennent d'assaut la grande mosquée de
la Mecque
car au regard de ces images on s'est
battus avec acharnement dans les salles
de prière les couloirs les minarets
autour de l'esplanade de la cave
le siège du RA près de deux semaines
et fera plusieurs centaines de victimes
on ignore tout des motivations de ce
commando il marquera durablement la
famille royale
[Musique]
avec des
ultrasons encore plus conservateurs que
qui disait au Saoudite vous êtes des
mauvais musulmans et donc on démontre
qu'on est des bons musulmans et donc on
ferme on annule tous les signes
d'ouverture
le théâtre la littérature
et une forme de liberté religieuse
[Musique]
c'est à cette époque que salaire fusane
décide de quitter l'Arabie Saoudite
il part en Égypte puis au Liban il ne
revient que rarement dans son pays
moi je suis d'une famille très pieuse
et pour eux mon engagement dans
l'industrie du cinéma et de la vidéo
c'était un péché
les tensions religieuses sont un sujet
sensible en Arabie Saoudite et ici nous
sommes constamment écoutés
en fait il y avait deux camps opposés le
gouvernement qui autorisait le cinéma
et les religieux qui considéraient ça
comme un péché vous savez je ne suis pas
un religieux je suis un libéral et
l'agent du ministère nous interrompt et
indique à notre interlocuteur
qu'il vaut mieux ne pas aborder se
passer douloureux
l'entretien s'arrête là mais ça là va
tout de même nous présenter quelqu'un
à quelque part une université flambant
neuve accueille environ 10 000 étudiants
à sa tête le docteur Shira
regardez-moi ça regardez ce que vous
avez fait pour nous Dieu vous garde tout
ça c'est grâce à vos efforts
c'est le premier saoudien à avoir suivi
des études de cinéma à Hollywood un
ancien camarade de classe de George
Lucas
et
j'étais dans l'une des universités les
plus importantes de Californie où sont
passés les plus grands producteurs et
réalisateurs mais quand je suis rentré
au pays c'était impossible de travailler
dans l'industrie du cinéma alors je me
suis mise à étudier la télévision
cet université c'est sa fierté
dans ces studios équipés avec du
matériel dernier cri se forme la
promotion 2023 de l'école de cinéma ok
ça tourne action
elle peut te présenter je m'appelle
Nawaf Mohamed bakabbas
joindre notre école
d'abord j'en ai beaucoup entendu parler
et les gens que je connais qui ont un
diplôme de cette école ont de bons
métiers aujourd'hui
moi je suis tombée amoureuse de la
réalisation je veux vraiment faire des
films si Dieu le veut
chers
on travaille dans l'industrie du cinéma
depuis les années 60 le docteur chia et
moi-même on a été en Égypte en Europe au
Maroc en Tunisie
tu comprends
internet a longtemps été la seule
fenêtre sur le monde
les Saoudiens se sont appropriés ce
moyen d'expression sur Youtube et les
réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
malgré la censure
cette vidéo satirique date de 2013 elle
compte 17 millions de vues
[Musique]
depuis l'interdiction des salles en 1980
quelques dizaines de longs métrages en
tout de même été tourné dans le pays
en visite à Cannes en 2013
la réalisatrice saoudienne Haïfa Al
Mansour expliquait avoir du tourné en se
cachant de la police des mœurs et
parlait à ses équipes au talkie-walkie
vous savez dans le pays les sexes sont
séparés donc je devais rester dans un
camion c'est la norme ici les gens ne
s'attendent pas à voir des femmes
travaillaient en pleine rue
son film watchda primé à Venise raconter
l'histoire d'une jeune fille confrontée
aux règles strictes d'une société où les
femmes vivent confinées
[Musique]
Mohamed Ben Salman a alors 32 ans il
fait lui-même partie de cette génération
à vide de loisirs
mais son calcul est aussi politique il a
vu chez son voisin égyptien et en
Tunisie les printemps arabes ou c'est
d'anciens dirigeants à l'exil
[Musique]
il comprend vite qu'il faut donner de
l'air à son pays scléroser
c'est la jeunesse la plus connectée du
monde c'est le nombre de comptes
Facebook ou YouTube par habitant le plus
élevé du monde et c'est aussi la
jeunesse qui a le taux d'obésité le plus
élevé du monde donc c'est comme si
c'était une jeunesse qui était
connectée sur le monde et enfermé chez
elle c'est un risque politique
absolument majeur et donc lui il dépasse
ce risque en disant aux jeunes je suis
de votre côté je suis du côté
d'ouverture je suis du côté du progrès
ce qu'il fait en Arabie il est très
intelligent parce qu'il est en train de
leur offrir une fenêtre pour respirer
qui n'est pas politique qui les
pousserait pas à une mobilisation
politique
mais cette nouvelle Arabie Saoudite
c'est aussi un autre visage beaucoup
moins avenant
le prince commence par réprimer durement
ce qui conteste sa politique et d'abord
les religieux conservateurs ils
n'hésitent pas à emprisonner ce qui
refuse l'ouverture de la société
comme Jamal racheloggi journaliste exilé
critique du régime
ça devient la dictature d'un seul homme
il prend le contrôle de tout il crée un
environnement d'intimidation et de peur
les Saoudiens sont réduits au silence
les choses ne sont pas transparentes et
ce n'est pas une bonne façon de réformer
le pays il doit faire quelque chose
[Musique]
la dernière image de racheli a fait le
tour du monde à l'intérieur du consulat
d'Arabie saoudite à Istanbul il sera
torturé assassiné puis démembré par des
agents du prince
lina alasloul est installé à Bruxelles
c'est une activiste saoudienne une
militante des droits de l'homme
ici elle peut se déplacer sans crainte
d'être arrêté interrogé par les
autorités
là-bas les militants des droits des
femmes sont emprisonnés par dizaine sa
propre sœur Luigi s'était filmé au
volant d'une voiture lorsqu'il était
encore interdit aux femmes de conduire
c'était en mai 2018
de la frontière saoudienne je conduis
une voiture qui est la mienne avec un
permis émirati j'essaye de continuer on
verra bien ce qui va se passer
en prison elle sera torturée
[Musique]
avant d'être libéré sans pouvoir sortir
du pays
aujourd'hui le régime autorise enfin les
femmes à prendre le volant
mais il poursuit la répression
[Musique]
ce qui est nouveau maintenant c'est que
même les personnes qui ne sont pas
connues qui n'ont aucun poids aucune que
personne ne connaît se font aussi
arrêter un prisonnier à des décennies en
prison donc ça c'est par exemple le cas
donc après que ma sœur soit sorti de
prison une femme qui s'appelle
Selma sheerave a été condamné à 34 ans
de prison pour m'avoir retweeté moi dans
un tweet où je parlais de de ma sœur
donc en fait le fait de parler de ma
sœur est un crime en soi maintenant et
c'est vraiment c'est pas une exception
qui a été condamné à 45 ans pour aussi
des tweets
depuis la capitale belge Linah peut
visionner les dernières créations du
cinéma saoudien
mais elle le sait cette ouverture est
une façon de donner au régime une image
moderne respectable
elle déplore le silence des artistes des
réalisateurs alors qu'il disposent
désormais d'une audience mondiale
je vais pas critiquer les gens qui
maintenant ont trouvé donc ont des
portes ouvertes mais au final c'est vrai
que quand on participe à ce genre
d'événements sans pouvoir parler sans
pouvoir critiquer sans pouvoir
questionner même
on est définitivement parti on fait
définitivement partie d'un d'une
campagne plus grande que nous quoi de
promotion de promotion du régime
malgré ses remises en cause les
professionnels du cinéma du monde entier
n'ont pas résisté à l'appel des
pétrodollars
[Musique]
le marché saoudien aiguise les
convoitises la population est jeune
riche prête à payer plus de 20 dollars
la place
et cet homme est bien décidé à en
profiter pasal balthieuor distribue la
plupart des films du pays dans des
nouveaux multiplexes monumentaux il
tient à nous montrer cette salle et ses
colonnades grandioses au cœur de Jeddah
[Musique]
il le sait ici le potentiel du 7e art
est infini
aujourd'hui on a 500 écrans dans le pays
qu'on a construit en seulement 4 ans
et on peut dire que l'Arabie Saoudite
c'est 40 45 % du box-office de tout le
moyen-orients
pour la deuxième fois en décembre
dernier
Jeddah a accueilli un festival
international de cinéma
sur le tapis rouge paillettes robe
glamour et sourire de circonstances
pyzel beltiore et son équipe ne boudent
pas leur plaisir
[Musique]
les possibilités sont désormais sans fin
il peut travailler dans son pays pour
les Saoudiens avant on ne pouvait pas
faire de film commerciaux où est-ce
qu'on les aurait diffusés donc on
faisait des films on voyageait à travers
le monde pour les présenter dans les
plus gros festivals étrangers mais
impossible de les montrer en Arabie
Saoudite maintenant on peut
à ses côtés Sharon Stone Mélanie Laurent
Jackie Chan Charlotte Gainsbourg et
Antonio Banderas le jury du festival
était présidé par Oliver Stone
je pense que ceux qui critiquent
l'Arabie Saoudite devraient venir
visiter cet endroit il y a beaucoup pas
voir
[Applaudissements]
sous les lustres de l'hôtel du festival
nous nous sommes mis dans les pas de
Daniel's skin producteur français
spécialisé dans les films arabes et ça
va et toi
il a constamment un collègue deux films
à Cannes un film à Venise et une série
Marvel Disney un ami a salué
il a même prévu une petite attention
pour le patron du festival
[Musique]
cette boîte de chocolat la moindre des
choses pour celui qui peut lui ouvrir
tant de portes
que les gens qui aiment le football qui
vont pas avoir la Coupe du Monde au
Qatar pourquoi il se réveille au dernier
moment il cherche des financements les
productions européennes manquent
d'argent et selon lui les Saoudiens sont
des interlocuteurs sérieux amoureux de
cinéma et soucieux d'investir
intelligemment
les conditions économiques c'est comme
avec n'importe quel partenaire il y a un
retour sur investissement à voir c'est
évident le mirage de l'argent facile de
mon arabe ça n'existe pas ça existe
peut-être dans des facilités d'être bien
reçu et tout ça mais dès que vous
rentrez dans le vif du sujet pour
tourner du film c'est un vrai rapport
économique au cinéma
dans ce salon réservé aux producteurs
la France a même son propre pavillon
le pays forme de jeunes cinéastes
saoudiens facilite les contacts
Charles-Henri gros est attaché au
consulat pour lui plus rien n'est
interdit dans le cinéma ce pays qui
s'ouvre à vitesse grand V la France doit
l'accompagner
le bilan en termes de trois humains etc
de pays ça c'est quelque chose avec
lequel la France est balaise
vous m'interrogez sur le sujet du cinéma
je resterai sur la question du cinéma
l'offre présentée qui est aussi en salle
en ville à zéro censure
ce festival est une parenthèse de
liberté dans un pays où tout expression
est encadré
le jour de l'ouverture les organisateurs
ont mis en avant
[Musique]
le bleu du caftan de la marocaine
Marianne Touzani
qui évoque ouvertement l'homosexualité
une seule fois il ne sera pas distribué
commercialement dans le royaume en ce
qui concerne les films destinés au grand
public censure ou interdiction son cours
certains dessins animés par exemple ont
été prohibées parce qu'ils évoquent des
couples de même sexe ou des scènes de
nudités la chaîne d'État Alec Paris a
c'est d'ailleurs inquiété de certains
extraits floutés à l'antenne dénonçant
l'influence subversive des valeurs
occidentales
où il y a des stars internationales qui
viennent habiller comme au Festival de
Cannes où il y a des films globaux enfin
qui pourraient être montré dans
n'importe quel autre festival le vrai
sujet c'est ce qu'ils vont être diffusés
en Arabie et à quel avec quel ampleur
ça je pense que les films avec une
connotation politique
ils vont ils seront jamais diffusés ils
sont jamais diffusés en Arabie
le film ne passe pas il trouve pas de
distributeur
l'homme clé du cinéma saoudien
c'est lui
Abdullah président de la Commission du
Film pour financer le secteur il dispose
d'un budget quasiment illimité c'est un
ingénieur et un réalisateur primé et il
se moque des critiques occidentales il
assume un cinéma en accord avec les
valeurs saoudiennes et réfute toute idée
de propagande
concernant l'Arabie Saoudite
avant notre pays était accusé de ne pas
avoir d'industrie du film de ne pas
soutenir les réalisateurs
et maintenant on a ce soutien on a cette
industrie et on nous accuse de
l'utiliser pour redorer notre image
cette hypocrite c'est notre droit de
raconter nos propres histoires et de le
faire au cinéma qui est l'une des plus
belles formes d'art
développer le cinéma ne sert pas
seulement à montrer une image moins
sulfureuse aux Occidentaux
jusqu'à quand les Saoudiens pourront-ils
profiter de la rente pétrolière
l'or noir crée peu d'emplois et
entretient les inégalités les plus
riches sont dispensés de travailler les
autres subissent un chômage élevé
une économie à deux vitesses dans un
état
omnipotent que le prince veut réformer
[Musique]
et ça ça veut dire des formations ça
veut dire travailler dans le secteur
privé plutôt que le public ça veut dire
un peu comme en France dans le don
travaille plus pour gagner plus s'ils
veulent améliorer leur statut sociaux
économique a travaillé plus et pas dans
l'état mais plutôt dans le privé
le royaume s'est doté d'un plan la
vision 2030 affichée partout à côté des
visages du prince et du roi Salman son
père
un budget de mille milliards de dollars
pour transformer l'économie investir
dans le tourisme les nouvelles
technologies et les projets gigantesques
comme Neo
bande-annonce de blockbusters pour cette
cité futuriste conçue par des
spécialistes des effets spéciaux
en plein désert sera construite de Line
la ligne un seul bâtiment de 170 km de
long et 500 mètres de haut aux promesses
écologiques douteux
[Musique]
à peine
et le cinéma il y a déjà sa place
quelques studios et ses bungalows dans
le sable le régime veut attirer dans ce
désert des équipes de films du monde
entier il promet de payer 40% du budget
de chaque tournage sans impôts mais
homme sera un royaume dans le royaume
avec ses propres lois différentes du
reste du pays
l'opération de communication est menée
par des consultants étrangers recrutés à
grand frais
attention il y a une marche
très bien impressionnant
l'Australien Wayne Borg et de passage
dans le pays il est venu vanter les
équipements dernier cri de Neon
notre village des médias s'étendra sur
un million de mètres carrés nous aurons
entre 45 et 50 studios de cinéma de jeux
vidéo des espaces de travail dédiés pour
les incubateurs de start-up ce sera le
premier centre de média intégré au monde
mais au-delà de l'affichage impossible
d'en savoir plus
vous dites que NEOM aura un statut
particulier qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
est-ce que je peux parler de ça
on aura nos propres lois nos règles pour
pouvoir attirer les meilleurs talents
les meilleures entreprises pour pousser
notre ambition de créer un centre avec
une vraie puissance économique et
sociale
les éléments de langage sont nébuleux
mais le calcul est simple faire
travailler des équipes de cinéma anéome
c'est injecté des millions de dollars
dans l'économie locale
se diversifier c'est aussi encourager le
tourisme
bienvenue à
[Musique]
la frontière sud de l'ancien royaume
nabatéen il y a 2000
[Musique]
la route des caravaniers qui
transportaient leurs épices vers la
Méditerranée
peu de voyageurs étrangers ont déjà
exploré ces montagnes mais le pays
accorde des visas touristiques depuis
du temps de l'ignorance avant l'Islam
aujourd'hui des centaines de guides
locaux anglophones ont été formés comme
machael alenzi elle est ici depuis le
début il y a 4 ans
donc si vous voulez bien venir je vais
vous montrer les gravures des dieux
gouvernement n'investisse ici c'était
ouvert mais sans organisation sans rien
pas de garde pas de guide
je suis fière parce que je suis d'ici je
suis né à Alula je garde en mémoire tous
les sites et aujourd'hui c'est une fille
d'alola qui fait la visite
l'objectif est de créer un million
d'emplois d'accueillir 100 millions de
visiteurs d'ici 2030
l'état compte utilisé le cinéma pour
changer l'image du pays et manifestement
pour ses touristes espagnols
regarde comme c'est beau c'est super
joli la formule fonctionne c'est tombe
on croirait celle qu'il y a en Indonésie
comment comment vous avez connu l'Arabie
Saoudite via les films et Instagram et
quel film alors ceux qui parlent du pays
je trouve ça super intéressant
tout le monde me dit non mais ça va pas
les droits de l'homme tout ça mais moi
je leur réponds que c'est faux que ça
n'a rien à voir avec ce qu'on voit sur
internet par exemple
[Musique]
du cinéma et de l'image
alors ils ont fait appel à un pro
l'Américain Philippe jokes venu tout
droit du Texas est en charge de
l'hébergement à alola
tout ça c'est neuf on fait en sorte de
l'entretenir et on est dans un paysage
magnifique
[Musique]
de films quand un hôtel spécialement
conçu pour loger les équipes de tournage
de films
et ici il y a de plus en plus de
demandes
là nous sommes à la phase une avec 150
chambres dans la phase 2 on va en
construire tout autant donc on en aura
300 tout on est à 20 minutes des décors
naturels incroyables d'Aloha et on
construit aussi deux studios en dur au
sud de l'endroit où nous sommes
ici ont été accueillis les techniciens
de plusieurs super productions
américaines
et du premier long-métrage saoudien
tourné sur place
le cinéma vient donner un coup de pouce
au tourisme pour développer les
infrastructures et faire connaître la
destination
plus les gens voient ces paysages
naturels uniques sur un écran lui
voudront venir les voir en vrai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
retour au cinéma de Jeddah
à la fin de la première séance de leur
vie nous retrouvons les trois jeunes
femmes Saloua Safia et rime
elles ont été touchées par l'histoire
d'une danseuse sud-coréenne
à la destinée tragique
oui j'ai encore les larmes aux yeux
c'est un très bon film ça dénonce plein
de choses et puis c'est la première fois
que je vois quelque chose de ce genre
d'habitude je regarde plutôt des films
d'action ou des comédies c'était
vraiment bien
[Musique]
une ouverture contrôle
une économie diversifiée
une liberté de créer sans critiquer
c'est le projet de société que le prince
héritier a imposé par la force
mais ces nouvelles possibilités
s'inscriront-elles dans la durée
[Musique]
un certain moment les gens développent
le concept de droit de ce qu'ils ont
c'est pas un privilège qu'on vient
d'acquérir c'est un droit ça fait partie
du quotidien mais on a déjà vu des
sociétés verraient complètement dans le
dans le sens inverse avec l'usage de
beaucoup de violence et de répression
et donc voilà ça reste à voir mais si
vous me demandez là sur le court terme
est-ce que il y a des changements ou des
réformes ou qui peuvent être remises en
considération oui c'est possible parce
que ça dépend d'une seule personne
[Musique]
fragile ou pérenne
l'ouverture des cinémas est une vitrine
de l'Arabie Saoudite d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
l'avenir dira ce que la jeunesse du pays
fera de cette fenêtre sur le monde
et si elle appellera d'autres
changements dans le pays
[Musique]
voilà pour ce document signé Thomas paga
et Mathieu Baudoin c'est la fin de ce
magazine on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
reporter sur France 24
[Musique]